très attendu dans la communauté
scientifique j'imagine que vous l'avez
vu le communauté d'éthique du CNRS a
publié un avis sur la dimension éthique
de la crise sanitaire la vie elle tourne
pas autour du pot il vous met
directement et nommément en cause avec
notamment Didier raouth et le professeur
Péronne vous êtes accusé de populisme
scientifique quel est votre réponse dans
c'est l'histoire de chloroquine c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
intéressant à regarder toutes les études
montrent
rétrospective prospective que les trucs
cycloroqués ne diminuent pas la
mortalité ne diminue pas le passage en
réanimation et donc à court terme marche
pas on pourrait dire ça ne marche pas et
en fait il y a une question que toutes
les scientifiques se posent c'est que
lorsque c'est les Chinois qu'il avait
démontré en premier ce qui est lorsque
vous donnez un antiviral
hydroxycloroquinois tout de suite tout
de suite au début de la maladie alors
vous avez moins de virus très rapidement
dans le nez
et c'est ceux qui s’est passé en
particulier à Marseille qui était au
fond le seul hôpital qui était prêt à
dépister immédiatement les gens et donc
on pouvait commencer immédiatement à
donner un antiviral mais sur cette
question du populisme scientifique
est-ce que vous considérez vous avez
contribué à
dire non je disais ça parce que c'est
important je veux dire que ça n'a jamais
été prouvé on n'a jamais fait d'études
sur en double aveugle l'erreur aussi
drôle c'est pas uniquement l'erreur des
autres que
milhydroxyde au début comme tout
antiviral au début je suis persuadé que
c'est quelque chose qui diminue la
présence du virus ensuite sur le
populisme si j'ai une chose à me
reprocher c'est la pétition aux Français
avril 2020 oui parce que les gens à
voter sur une question si technique
c'est un peu considéré
la question elle était posée comme ça
c'est pour ça que mais ça a été mal
compris c'est que je n'avais pas admis
le fait qu'un ministre de la Santé
empêche tout médecin de prescrire un
médicament ça ça veut jamais existé
encore en France et c'est cette idée là
que j'ai voulu combattre
est-ce que c'est normal que on puisse
décider comme ça c'est comme si la
limite de la culture disait ça c'est
beau ça c'est les mais là vous vous
mettre ça vous ne pouvez pas prescrire
ce médicament médicament quand même
prescrit depuis plus de 50 ans des
milliards regretter avoir fait ça à voir
non je regrette non oui c'est ce que
maladroit de le dire aux Français comme
ça parce que eux comme on peut très bien
dire ils n'ont pas la clé eux-mêmes sur
Oui ou Non et donc c'est chloroquine par
contre les Français avaient le droit de
dire on ne comprend pas pourquoi un
ministre de la Santé empêche les
médecins de prescrire tel médicament les
médecins ils peuvent prescrire les
médicaments qu'ils veulent
[Musique]